the U.S women's soccer team
apparently had a game over the weekend
I'm not the biggest fan can't say I've
ever watched even 30 seconds of a US
Women's soccer game but during the
national anthem a significant portion of
the team decided not to put their hands
over their hearts but to stand somberly
hands behind their back disrespecting
the Star-Spangled Banner
you go one girl puts her hand on her
heart good suspectful well they don't
even teach the kids to do it
there's another girl okay there's
another girl has her hand on her heart
the rest of the vast majority of the
team there's another one
at least two to one they're
disrespecting the flag not putting their
hand on their heart
standing stoically they're not willing
to
they're not willing to take the knee
that got all that kind of trouble in the
NFL
okay there we go there's one guy
with his hand on his heart
it's at least half
are not doing it sort of more a little
more than
goals
no hand on their heart
so it's a subtler form of disrespect
than the Colin Kaepernick stuff and then
you can see because you could tell this
was a political problem the cameras
started zooming in on the girls who do
have their hands on their Hearth but you
can't ignore it it's just so clear so
many of them are not doing this why are
they not doing it are they not doing it
because they were brought up the wrong
way like those little kid they've got
these little kids standing in front of
the women's soccer team they don't have
their hands on their heart I don't blame
the kids for that the kids were just
brought up the wrong way their parents
didn't teach them how they're supposed
to stand for the The Star Spangled
Banner
the adults should know better and
furthermore I'm skeptical that this is
just some innocent mistake one because
they're they're teammates have their
hands on their hearts so they're
noticing that this is what one does
and two because U.S women's soccer has
historically been extremely left-wing
and unpatriotic I think of that awful
woman Megan rapino as the poster child
of this
and because in sports broadly there has
been this this Rebellion Against The
Star Spangled Banner and the flag which
symbolizes the whole country so what are
we to do about this
what I would be inclined to do at the
very least is fire those women who
disrespect the flag from the team just
fire them out right
and potentially what I would do because
this has been a problem in U.S women's
soccer for so long is just disband the
team just get rid of it and maybe you
think that's a little bit harsh but then
let me ask you this question what's the
point of U.S women's soccer
what's the point
is it to get a lot of viewership it
doesn't get that much viewership okay
it's not as bad as the WNBA but it
doesn't get a lot of viewership
but even if it were a really popular
team
that's not the point that's not what
it's for the point of a U.S national
team is to represent the U.S Nation
and so if the team
disrespects the nation that it exists to
represent then the team does not fulfill
its main purpose and should you should
just disband it and you can either start
again or just not have one no one's
going to miss the U.S women's soccer
team so just get rid of it
if the salt loses its savor
wherewith shall it be salted what is the
point of the salt no then it's good for
nothing
and ought to be trampled underfoot right
now text Knowles to 98 98 98 we are days
away from the Durbin Accords the
greatest threat to the US Dollar's
Global dominance in the past 80 years on
August 22nd brics Nations Brazil Russia
India China South Africa are expected to
announce the launch of a new
international super currency fully
backed by gold or other Commodities this
is part of their long-term plan to
supplant the U.S and the dollar as
cornerstones of the Global Financial
system you can protect your IRA or 401K
from The Fallout from this Landmark
Announcement by diversifying with gold
from Birch gold historically gold has
been a safe haven in times of high
uncertainty which is
right now when currencies fail gold is a
safe haven how much more time does the
Dollar have protect your savings with
gold Birch gold has an A plus rating
with the Better Business Bureau
thousands of happy customers text
Knowles Canada wlas 298 98.98 get your
free info kit on gold if a central bank
digital currency becomes a reality it
will be nice to have some gold to depend
upon text nulls kwles to 98.98 98. right
now head on over to hillsdale.edu
Knowles are you a few years or maybe
decades out of school and wondering what
the heck did I even learn and what was
the point you might think to yourself
that you don't have time to learn
something new if that's you then know
this you're not alone it's not too late
since 1844 Hillsdale College has been
providing education in faith freedom and
character they have taken some of the
core classes that they teach on campus
and made them available for free online
for anyone who wants to learn that is
right for free there are 39 free courses
to choose from ranging from the U.S
Constitution the Book of Genesis to free
market economics they are easy to follow
they are self-paced so you can start
whenever you want in fact you can start
right now it's everything you need all
in one place no long-term commitment go
to Hillsdale College let them be your
guide go to hillsdale.edu Knowles to
enroll no cost easy to get started
hillsdale.edu Knowles to register
Hillsdale dot edu slash Knowles we have
forgotten in the Modern Age not just on
the left but even many people on the
right that things have a purpose
a thing is defined in fact by its
purpose
you to use the some of the more formal
language some of the Aristotelian
language you are not
you as a person are not defined by
merely by your purpose like in the way
that the leftist ears tumbler is defined
by bringing delicious leftist tears into
my mouth that's what it's for if it can
no longer do that then it has no purpose
it's lost its Essence you're a little
different than that because you're a
primary substance and you're made by God
you're not an artifact made by man but
at the very least these things that are
just man-made constructs they have a
purpose they're defined by that if they
don't fulfill that
then get rid of it we have such Mission
drift such Mission creep in in all of
these man-made institutions now do you
remember during the Obama Administration
we were told that the point of NASA was
to make peace with the Muslim World NASA
NASA the thing that exists to go to the
moon and to go to outer space and to
take pictures of the stars we just said
no that actually the real purpose is to
make friends with the Muslim world
that's it the real the real purpose of
the US Army is to make people feel
really good about their gender identity
or whatever
no that's not no if a point of the US
Army is to kill people okay it's not
it's not too it's not to really come to
recognize white rage and correct the
deep-seated oppression of the patriarchy
of the no the point of the US Army is to
kill our enemies that's the point of it
if we're not doing that or if we're
putting the cart before the horse then
we need to structurally change that
and until there are consequences for
this kind of mission creep and in the
case of the U.S women's soccer team
undermining the very totally undermining
the very purpose of the thing until
there are consequences and someone goes
in there and says no we Define things by
their purpose and when they contradict
that purpose we cut it out
when when we in a phrase
stop pretending that freedom quote
unquote is an end unto itself
and start to remember that freedom is a
means to human flourishing that freedom
I'm now I'm just channeling the founding
fathers and all great Statesmen in
history that freedom is the right to do
what we ought to do that end in sight
not merely the ability to do whatever we
want to amuse ourselves until we die
we're not going to be able to fix these
problems until we recognize that Liberty
in America
is an instrument for the purpose of
attaining the blessings of liberty there
it is it's right there in our
constitution until we recognize that
we're going to continue to put the cart
before the horse and things are going to
become even more and more absurd boy
what a great clip that was make sure
that you ring the bell subscribe to the
Michael Knowles show channel we'll see
you next time